[Music]
those were never in Papua New Guinea in
the middle of the Pacific and
Neanderthals were never in the Americas
and it turns out that American Indians
and the Papua New Guineans have more
Neanderthal blood than Europeans here
you can see a green 2010 this is on the
seminal article which they published a
striking observations that Neanderthals
are as closely related to a Chinese and
named and pop one individual as to a
French individual even though
morphologically recognizable and
amethyst exists only in the fossil
record of Europe and Western Asia this
may be explained by mixing of early
modern humans ancestral to present-day
non-africans when and adults in the
Middle East before their expansion into
Eurasia such a scenario is and here's
the politics of it listen to this such a
scenario is compatible with the
archaeological record which shows that
modern humans appeared in the Middle
East before 100 thousand years ago
whereas the Neanderthals existed in the
same region after this time probably
until 50 thousand years ago in other
words they're saying we met you know
anywhere between 50 what is it fifty
thousand and a hundred thousand years
ago we met with an end result in the
Middle East but we got a problem with
this and the problem is that to this day
we cannot show that whatever is in the
Middle East is Neanderthal let me read a
paper it comes from Adams burg 1998 and
what they do in this paper is they go
through and take from all the people who
research nan de Thal or you know
whatever the skeletons in the Middle
East and and these are the differences
that they find this these are their
comments and they just kind of made a
collection of all these and they show
you what is the property go to different
sites in Israel in Iraq and they and
they look at the bones and say these are
not
maybe that's the here's answer the first
statement that he makes there is
actually little evidence for the
existence of a Southwest Asiatic
Nanticoke population in Israel during
the Middle Paleolithic period another
common human fossils originally labeled
as near the thoughts were subsequently
reevaluated and defined otherwise a
horizontal mandibular foramen which
characterizes 61.5% of the Nano dolls is
absent in a mood one cocoon one and
shanidar one these are the caves
here's Kabara another cave inspection of
the available data reveals that most of
the listed for more fees are not in fact
exclusive to nano those but occur also
within other human groups including
recent populations moreover they are not
found in all handl thoughts skull
another cave in israel the skull remains
were eventually further disassociated
from this category nanda thought and
acknowledges early anatomically modern
Homo sapiens ok table hoon another cave
even though the two mandibles recovered
from table hoon were originally assigned
to the same local Neanderthal population
the morphological differences observed
between the two enabled a later
reappraisal to consider Kubuntu is
belonging to an anatomically modern Homo
sapiens another one the female skeleton
to whom one was considered by McGowan a
key to representing and athon related
human type morphological reexaminations
however do not seem to corroborate this
claim the claim for table once Nana the
affinities is not supported by the
evidence of mandibular morphology either
instead this line of evidence suggests
archaic Homo sapiens affinities for this
specimen coffin cop said another cave
capsule remains also originally
considered as Neanderthals were
eventually recognized as a MHS in other
words anatomically modern humans this
view was later corroborated by the
chronological evidence which suggesting
a much earlier
for these specimens a mood another one
revaluation of the morphological data
concerning of what one reveals that it
lacks many of the distinctive and adult
features a month one occiput deviates
markedly from the naina thought pattern
and its internal occipital protuberance
is on almost the same level as the
Indian rather resembling that of
anatomically modern humans and the last
one shanidar that's in Iraq the shot of
our sample does not display all the
characters commonly or exclusively found
in European and earth all crania so what
are these reading comments and
evaluations tell you that there were no
in the end of the Middle East at least
that's the important that they really
ate it the you the Neanderthal bones
yeah they they first called them the
other thoughts but then we evaluated
them as humans to fit some sort of
theory I think the bottom line here is
there is absolutely I think there's
quite a bit of consensus that the
samples found in the Middle East differ
measurably you know from the samples
found in Spain France and Germany in
other words there's a difference between
the so called nan Devils of Middle East
and the Nana those proper-- though the
ones we we identified with the first one
that we discovered so many dirty and
earth alls at all well they're saying
that what but these people are saying
yes all these bones they're not endeth
all at all
they're archaic humans and in fact it's
highly unlikely that Neanderthals who
develop in the arctic cold war no
clothes were barefooted walking in the
snow would move near the equator do
polar bears migrate to the equator
they're not gonna survive over there and
I don't
the end of those pecans that far south
either there is no reason for the
Neanderthals first to migrate that far
south and second we notice that there
are morphological differences between
the samples in the Middle East and those
in western but I thought you is the
offspring of humans and Neanderthals
that went to the Middle East
no no because here we're talking about
maybe 80 thousand years ago we're
talking about when they just when when
humans apparently were just coming out
of a plant that's how they met they met
they met supposing that that was the
first line of and and again we have no
evidence that even assuming these were
Nanda thoughts we have no evidence we
have not been able to place them at the
same time at the same place as of today
right we can't place the perpetrators
crying but let's assume that these were
Nanda thoughts it still wouldn't explain
the ten to one ratio yeah if humans
outnumbered naina thoughts ten to one as
the theory holds yeah we still should
have more nanda though blood from
Europeans then from everybody else and
if the agents have more than you
Europeans and they're the American
Indians have more than the Europeans
then all bets are off we don't know what
happened we got contaminated somehow
then open throw they're working
hypothesis if we met in the Middle East
the most common ancestry would be the
Middle East wouldn't it that's where the
that's where the biggest percentage of
DNA oh maybe not because remember it we
met in the Middle East
it was a White Nights one-night stand
kind that's where it started so yeah it
started but what I'm saying is then we
allegedly lived among the Neanderthals
in Europe for many thousands of years
and that's where the great majority of
both populations
why didn't we list what didn't we live
in the Middle East
why did they go to the Middle East and
then back to Europe no no it's not that
they left Europe's like they expanded
into really
right and you'd still think that the the
ground zero would be Middle East not
Europe no they came from from Europe to
the Middle East and we came from Africa
to the Middle East that's around zero
and so that would be the most and then
the little s little s little s little s
like anything that isn't the Middle East
would have less than a Middle East I see
it in a different way this is what the
way and that way they see it as well
here's a great population of
Mandeville's in europe the majority of
them were there was in what's in the
Middle East it's just a like a trickle
the the end of the empire it's like
you're talking about little island there
a little Peninsula where you know the
latter the farthest Nana thoughts live
let's assume that's true well so now
that the humans come over and they meet
these guys in the peninsula which is
look at the end of the Empire the the
Navigon Empire so they meet with them
and so they have a little bit of sex
there and then they go off to Asia well
that has to produce much less than the
invasion into Europe a ten to one ratio
of humans with nan Devils and they mix
for thousands of years and have kids you
know galore so that's that's so European
should have more now than anybody else
and that's not the case if Asians and
American Indians have more than
Europeans and all bets are off we don't
know what happened there working
hypothesis is wrong you cannot infer
that because everybody has approximately
2% Navajo blood in them that because of
that you know we proven that they made
it for TE that eighty thousand years ago
simply because we have more novel DNA
than Africa
[Music]
we'll go so what should we do with the
geeks that work at the Max Planck
Institute well let me tell you what I do
think
[Music]